[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au menu de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie voici
le programme de ce lundi 6 mars
un mardi qui s'annonce compliqué les
organisations syndicales appel à une
sixième journée de grève contre la
réforme des retraites l'intersyndicale
annonce une mobilisation massive et veut
mettre la France à l'arrêt les
perturbations s'annonce importante dans
les transports les écoles et dans
d'autres secteurs à quoi faut-il
s'attendre dans les Yvelines le point
dans cette édition c'était au théâtre de
Poissy samedi dernier 29 candidats
réunis pour un titre celui de Mr France
2023 Lysandre vendent Mulder originaire
de la Corse a remporté la finale du
concours présidé cette année par
Nathalie Pernaut Marquay Jessie et
Willens de confrères de radio sensation
a suivi l'élection on revient avec lui
sur l'événement et puis c'est parti pour
la 81e édition du Paris-Nice la
compétition cycliste s'était lancé du
département pour la 14e année
consécutive première étape hier à La
Verrière aujourd'hui la course au soleil
des marais de Bazainville l'occasion de
croiser les géants de la discipline
Yonas vin gueguard ou encore tadaï
pogatsar interview et immersion dans
cette édition et ce sera tout à l'heure
il y avait d'ailleurs que du cyclisme au
menu de ce week-end on fera tout à
l'heure un point sur le reste des
actualités sportives et des résultats
sportifs du week-end on présentera aussi
ce prochain événement prochain
rendez-vous prochain rendez-vous qui est
l'éco trail de Paris qui se tiendra le
18 mars au départ de l'île de loisirs de
50 ans en Yvelines autour de la table
vous le voyez ils sont nombreux il y a
Emmanuel le gros bonsoir notamment qui
est notre invité directeur recrutement
et de Capgemini France la société vient
de signer une chair sur les impacts
écologiques et sociaux avec l'école
d'ingénieur aiséo dont l'un des campus
c'est situé à Vélizy-Villacoublay en
quelques mots pour présenter Capgemini
elle accompagne les organisations dans
leur transformation digitale c'est ça
c'est exactement cela Captain mini c'est
une belle histoire française puisque
c'est une société qui est un peu plus de
50 ans et qui aujourd'hui est devenu une
multinationale on est plus de 350 000
personnes dans le monde et notre mission
c'est d'accompagner au quotidien nos
clients nos clients tous secteurs
d'activité dans leur transformation
digitale donc le monde de light le monde
de l'ingénierie tous les secteurs ils
passent donc la collaboration avec kezeo
dont on parlera tout à l'heure avec la
signature de cette chair à ma gauche il
y a Céline Charles et Gabriel Montier
bonsoir à vous deux de la rédaction de
TV 78 Gabriel Gonti on fera un point
avec vous sur les perturbations à
prévoir demain pour cette nouvelle
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites les informations
du jour se sera suivre avec vous Céline
sharles et au-delà de la grève qu'y
a-t-il dans l'actualité du jour on
parlera notamment de l'école cette école
de 1600 Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui a été
très sollicité aujourd'hui et puis bien
sûr on reviendra sur le palmarès du
guide Michelin qui est sorti également
aujourd'hui un invité de marque aussi au
château de Versailles à suivre bientôt
dans les Yvelines et puis je le disais
Jessie Willens je prononce bien à chaque
fois j'ai un petit doute de nos
confrères de radio sensation vous avez
l'habitude de retrouver dans quelques
reportages que l'on diffuse aussi sur TV
78 également les mages et vous avez
assisté vous à l'élection de Mister
France 2023 c'était samedi à Poissy
est-ce que c'était un événement
intéressant à suivre un événement très
intéressant et je pense qu'il faudrait
un peu plus le valoriser le médiatisé en
tout cas on va revenir sur ce cette
édition 2023 avec vous ce sera tout à
l'heure on présentera aussi l'expo le
paysage avec Florence Mercadet choqué
qui a l'habitude aussi d'intervenir sur
TV 78 comme avocate cette fois-ci elle
mettra sa casquette d'artiste peintre
pour nous parler de cette exposition
tout ça bien sûr après les prévisions
météo de demain
et demain matin le ciel sera dégagé sur
l'ensemble du département et quelques
nuages à prévoir mais nous aurons tout
de même de belles éclaircies au niveau
des températures comptées 4 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Versailles il
fera à 3 degrés à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi prévoyait de la pluie sur
une bonne partie des Yvelines seul le
secteur de Rambouillet devrait être
épargné selon la météo France côté
température il fera 8 degrés à Houdan
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles 7° à
Rambouillet et demain c'est la sainte
Félicité on fait le point tout de suite
sur les informations du jour dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
avec Céline Charles et vous le disiez il
y a un instant Céline l'école 2600
spécialisée dans la cybersécurité à 50
ans en Yvelines a été le théâtre ce
lundi de deux visites oui Grégory
Jean-Noël barreau ministre délégué de la
transition numérique et des
télécommunications
déployées par l'État il a également pu
échanger avec des étudiants on l'écoute
la cyber c'est un secteur porteur c'est
un métier d'avenir il nous faut répondre
à la menace qui progresse et pour ça on
a besoin de talents on a besoin de
neurones on a besoin de jeunes formés et
2600 fait partie de cette nouvelle
génération d'écoles qui se sont créés
pour 2600 c'est il y a deux ans pour
former ces talents dans la cyber
ici à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui est
par ailleurs un hub une capitale
numérique avec des grandes entreprises
avec d'autres écoles et universités
dans l'après-midi c'est Pierre Bédier
président du conseil départemental des
Yvelines qui s'y rendu pour une visite
cantonale cette quatrième journée de
rencontre s'inscrit dans le cycle de
visite de terrain du département et vise
à poursuivre le dialogue avec les
acteurs de la ville locale entre autres
pierre-bénith a pu discuter de l'avenir
de l'école écouter nous allons avoir une
discussion vient d'échanger la carte de
visite avec la Une des associés qui
dirige à l'établissement pour voir quel
aide on peut leur apporter dans le
développement de cette école aujourd'hui
ils accueillent un peu moins de 200
étudiants leur objectif est d'un
accueillir 300 dans des locaux
aujourd'hui qui sont mises à disposition
par Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la
communauté d'agglomération mais sans
doute sera-t-il nécessaire d'imaginer un
autre bâtiment quelque chose de plus
grand de plus vaste et peut-être je dis
bien peut-être le département
pourra-t-il jouer un rôle dans ce
nouveau bâtiment
un invité de marque à présent qui va
venir bientôt au château de Versailles
tout à fait il s'agit bien sûr du roi
Charles III le roi d'Angleterre il a
choisi la France et notamment le château
de Versailles pour sa première visite
d'État en tant que souverain il sera en
visite avec son épouse Camilla en France
du 26 au 29 mars prochain durant son
déplacement un dîner d'État avec le
président Emmanuel Macron et notamment
prévu au château on le rappelle sa mère
la reine Elisabeth II c'était elle-même
rendu à trois reprises dans la cité
royale des Yvelines un record pour un
chef d'État étranger il y avait
également fait sa première visite en
France dans le costume de Rennes mais
l'actualité du jour c'est aussi le
palmarès du guide Michelin les fameuses
étoiles du guide Michelin qui donc a été
dévoilé c'est palmarès ce lundi alors
chaque année récompense les meilleurs
restaurants sur plusieurs critères les
sept restaurants étoilés Michelin des
Yvelines ont gardé leur place on
retrouve la table du 11 le Gordon Ramsay
le numéro 3 le panoramique la table des
Bleus le village et le festin le
restaurant ruche à Gambais également
obtenu pour la première fois l'étoile
verte de la du qui récompense
l'innovation durable et l'approche
environnementale un challenge viral un
qui a fait le buzz sur les réseaux
sociaux qui va repasser par le
département et oui bien sûr
du défi devenu viral de la lucarne qui
reprendra sa tournée en 2023 et le
député car le livre l'a annoncé dans un
tweet sa première sera dans les Yvelines
ce challenge qui consiste à tirer et
faire entrer un ballon de football dans
une fenêtre depuis le trottoir d'en face
était né à Évry en Essonne en 2021 et
cette année la tournée sera accompagnée
de salon de l'emploi
Gabriel on va essayer un défi assez
populaire très populaire même qui a fait
le tour de France et qui était passé par
Poissy qui va donc faire son son retour
on va terminer avec la la Journée
mondiale de l'obésité c'était samedi et
le centre hospitalier de Rambouillet
dans les Yvelines il y a participé
effectivement tout un programme a été
réalisé par le centre hospitalier de
Rambouillet à l'initiative de
l'association poids plumes France alors
outre les conférences et les stands
d'information plusieurs activités
étaient proposées mise en situation
encore atelier sur la perception de sa
propre image corporelle l'objectif c'est
de faire de la prévention sur le baiser
en luttant contre l'abondance des idées
reçues en insistant sur l'importance du
dépistage parmi ces ateliers un quiz
diététique interactif était proposé par
une psychologue on l'écoute pour plus de
détails on va commencer à regarder ce
qu'on fait au quotidien toute la journée
notre comportement donc il y aura un
petit quiz sur les comportements que
j'ai proposé chaque participant va
choisir le comportement qui lui
correspond et puis on va regarder et
analyser chaque les comportements qui
sont le plus votés et à partir de ça on
va réfléchir à pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
que à 4h je mange avec les enfants alors
que j'ai pas faim par exemple qu'est-ce
qui se passe au niveau relationnel
derrière on va vraiment chercher ce qui
se passe derrière au niveau des pensées
des émotions et aussi des sensations
on va faire les liens au niveau
psychologique sur ce qui peut se jouer
et ce qui peut créer des comportements
qui sont pas du tout adaptés au niveau
alimentaire
merci merci Céline pour toutes ces
informations et si vous aussi un près de
chez vous vous êtes témoin d'une
information qui vous fait réagir
n'hésitez pas à le dire sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 78 news
alors autre information importante
Gabriel elle aura lieu dans la journée
de demain avec cette nouvelle journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites c'est une sixième journée de
mobilisation nationale tout à fait
Grégory et pour cette 6e journée de
grève les syndicats ont prévenu ils
souhaitent mettre le pays à l'arrêt pour
faire en temps leur revendications
Nicolas chameau secrétaire général de
l'Union départementale CGT des Yvelines
nous en dit plus sur la journée de
demain pour la manifestation parisienne
il y a plus de une vingtaine de quarts
au départ des Yvelines organisé par les
unisolocales et les et les syndicats
donc pas mal de cartes qui vont partir
des des usines que ça soit Renault Flins
que ça soit le Technocentre que ça soit
derbus d'Ariane beaucoup d'entreprises
et des préavis de grève très intéressant
donc normalement ça va être une grosse
journée sans trains avec énormément
d'entreprises à l'arrêt et belle
manifestation parisienne
un mardi qui s'annonce donc noir dans
les transports quels sont les prévisions
dans les Yvelines
comme pour les précédentes journées de
grève le trafic va être fortement
perturbé dans les Yvelines les lignes nu
l et j sont impactés vous le voyez
s'afficher sur vos écrans sur la ligne N
et j prévoyez intrins sur 5 sur la ligne
u intrins sur 3 côté RER intrafic
fortement perturbé et annoncé sur les
lignes A et B ou intrins sur trois
circulera ou sur la ligne C c'est un
train sur 5 qui circulera l'aviation est
également impactée Grégory 20 à 30% des
vols devraient être supprimés vous avez
pris vos dispositions en plateau pour
demain
télétravail télétravail pour vous voilà
on s'organise on sait cette journée de
grève alors côté éducation les syndicats
vont se mobiliser aussi demain sans
surprise les écoles vont être lourdement
impactés 60% des grévistes dans les
écoles primaires sont à prévoir demain
ça c'est au niveau national en revanche
il est difficile d'avoir des chiffres
dans les Yvelines les principaux
syndicats dont le FSU smupp 78 c'est
difficile à dire appel à une fermeture
totale des établissements la
mobilisation s'annonce donc importante à
noter que cette fois les secteurs de
l'énergie les éboueurs et les routiers
ont annoncé leur mobilisation reste à
savoir Grégory si cette grève sera
reconduite comme l'appelle certains
syndicats réponse demain et dans les
prochains jours pour cette nouvelle
journée de grève contre la réforme des
retraites merci Gabriel pour ces
précisions et on parle tout de suite
dans le 7 8 de la signature de cette
chaire sur les impacts écologiques et
sociaux entre l'école d'ingénieurs aiséo
et Cup Gemini France Emmanuel Legros qui
est directeur recrutement du groupe est
avec nous en plateau il y a aussi
Yannick Giro qui est connecté en
visioconférence bonsoir
vous êtes enseignants chercheurs dans
cette école d'ingénieurs dont l'un des
campus je le disais est basé dans les
Yvelines à
Vélizy-Villacoublay c'est d'ailleurs sur
ce campus qui a été signé cette chair en
termes de vocabulaire on parle de chair
pour être très concret qu'est-ce qu'une
chair pour que tout noter les
spectateurs puissent comprendre le sujet
le regroupement de d'entreprises qui sur
une thématique particulière au sein d'un
établissement d'enseignement supérieur
qui font participer financièrement de
façon directe par le biais de mes
compétences au développement de cette de
cette thématique et qui en contrepartie
obtient une visibilité
accrue très importante dans l'état donc
là renforcement du lien avec avec
Capgemini puisque la collaboration est
déjà ancienne entre aiséo et capgemi
pourquoi c'est intéressant pour Iseo
justement de collaborer avec capgemin on
va parler des thématiques qui seront
abordées dans cette chair mais pourquoi
cette collaboration est-elle
intéressante
il y a deux grands deux grands axes pour
nous c'est bénéficié de des compétences
d'un grand groupe qui est très impliqué
sur les sujets d'impact écologique et
sociaux alors Monsieur Legrand parlerait
mieux que moi mais par le biais
notamment du réseau communal
ce qui nous permet de bénéficier par le
biais du bénéfénat de compétences
d'enseignement d'activités pédagogiques
autour des impacts du numérique
d'analyse de cycle de vie d'inclusion de
thématiques liées à l'inclusion l'invité
etc ça c'est un premier un premier grand
grand point positif pour nous et le
deuxième c'est le fil en financement qui
nous permet notamment de faire vivre un
appel à projet
étudiant et salarié
qui a déjà deux ans mais
par la participation
voilà qui permet qui va nous permettre
de répondre à des à des projets
étudiants permettre à des étudiants ou à
des salariés de mener à bien des projets
liés à ces thématiques là on va parler
peut-être de quelqu'un de ces projets
justement côté Capgemini qu'est-ce qui
est intéressant dans le fait de
collaborer avec avec les autres
capgeminy
recrutant énormément de jeunes chaque
année donc les relations fortes avec des
écoles qui sont spécialistes de nos
domaines d'activité est essentielle donc
les éos c'est Vélizy mais c'est pas que
billies c'est Angers c'est l'un des
campus
est présent partout en France c'est
c'est aussi la capacité pour nous d'être
d'avoir accéder à ce vivier de
compétences dans là où nous avons besoin
de ces compétences et vous travaillez
avec d'autres écoles kezeo c'est alors
nous obtenons un plan de partenariat
avec avec beaucoup d'écoles en France
nous avons à peu près
200 250 écoles cibles en France tout
partout tout partout en France et nous
nous mettons régulièrement en place ce
type de ce type d'accord ce type de
partenariat alors c'est une chaire ou
c'est un partenariat plus classique
entre guillemets mais l'objectif il est
au travers de ces personnages d'avoir
une approche aussi ce qu'on aime bien
dire 360 degrés c'est à dire une
approche qui va nous permettre à la fois
de travailler notre marque employeur
donc parler de nos métiers des métiers
dans lesquels ces étudiants seront
impliqués s'ils viennent chez nous les
aider aussi à trouver un job au travers
de l'ateliers RH ça rapproche finalement
de mon étudiant avec aussi le monde de
l'entreprise on dit souvent les demandes
peuvent être éloignées en tout cas et
demandeur et après l'entreprise ça
permet de ça permet de faire matcher le
tout de faire match le tout notamment
dans les aspects pédagogiques puisque on
travaille avec les associations
étudiantes mais l'aspect pédagogique est
quelque chose qui est important et
notamment dans le cadre de ses activités
RSE on va pouvoir
sensibiliser ses étudiants
à ce qu'on a l'impact du numérique sur
un sujet sociétal qui qui préoccupe tout
le monde aujourd'hui qui est quel
réchauffement de la planète et donc
l'empreinte carbone de nos activités
digitales Yannick viro vous avez
commencé à parler de quelques projets
quelle thématiques concrètement sur
quelle thématique vous allez travailler
au sein de au sein de cette chair
[Musique]
comme je vous l'ai dit il y a plusieurs
axes donc le premier axe sur lequel on
va travailler c'est bien sûr l'axe
formation c'est nous nous un des
objectifs
affichés par l'école c'est de renforcer
nos enseignements sur les sur les sur
les thématiques liées à aux impacts
écologiques et sociaux ça passe par à la
fois une meilleure compréhension des
enjeux monsieur Legros a parlé de
réchauffement climatique mais ça va même
bien au-delà des impacts
environnementaux en général
développer l'esprit critique pour
essayer de faire le truc un peu
[Musique]
mes attentes sont de d'avoir accès à
aux compétences métiers propres de
Capgemini à cette thématique notamment
en termes d'écossements mais aussi de
pouvoir développer l'appel à projet qui
est encore récent il y a eu que deux
éditions essayer d'en faire un vrai bel
outil pour que nos salariés et nos
étudiants se s'approprient ces enjeux et
mettre en mettre en valeur leurs idées
Emmanuel le gros
comment l'évoquait c'est bien
sensibilisé les étudiants à cette
problématique de développement durable
donc au travers de méthodologie et de
d'approche qui vont permettre leur
permettre de faire un et des
développements digitaux qui sont propres
entre guillemets mais bien évidemment
c'est continuer à travailler cette
relation très forte cette proximité très
forte qu'on a avec les héros depuis
avant 2012 notre premier partenariat
c'est 2012 d'envoyer ça fait ça fait
plus de 10 ans et le généraliser sur
l'ensemble des des autres sites pas
seulement Vélizy mais bien évidemment
Angers et Dijon merci d'être venu en
parler en plateau Emmanuel Legros
directeur recrutement du groupe
Capgemini il y avait aussi Yannick
vieiro qui était connecté avec nous en
visioconférence je rappelle vous êtes
enseignants chercheurs dans cette école
d'ingénieur basée et partout en France
mais dont l'un des campus est quand même
situé sur le territoire des Yvelines du
côté de Vélizy-Villacoublay
dans l'actualité c'était ce week-end il
y avait cette élection de Mister France
on va revenir sur cet événement qui se
déroulait du côté de Poissy c'est un
concours qui existe Jessie depuis 20 ans
et donc la finale de l'édition 2023
c'était du côté du théâtre de Poissy
alors vous étiez présent pour Radio
sensation mais vous allez faire vivre à
nos téléspectateurs refaire vivre à la
TV 68 le téléspectateurs TV 78 cet
événement que soit dans les préparatifs
les répétitions et l'élection en
elle-même vous avez rien loupé
effectivement 28 candidats au départ un
venus représenter chacun leur région
avec bien sûr l'Île-de-France avec
Raphaël Oro impossible de passer à côté
de ce francilien un mètre 89 78 kg
étudiant en STAPS à Paris Saclay il est
originaire de Dourdan il m'a expliqué
pourquoi il souhaitait représenter
justement notre région alors moi je
viens d'une petite campagne dans le 91
et donc j'aimerais la représenter ce
soir pour montrer que l'île de France ne
s'étend pas qu'à Paris et que donc la
ville de Dourdan qui est un peu connue
pour son château midi là notamment sont
un peu représentés en Île-de-France tout
d'abord il y a Paris mais il y a pas que
Paris il y a aussi Fontainebleau
notamment avec la forêt c'est une grande
diversité l'Ile-de-France et donc on va
essayer de la représenter au maximum ce
soir alors tout l'après-midi les
candidats se sont préparés dans une
ambiance plutôt détendue mais si rien
n'allait même si rien pardon n'a laissé
été au hasard tout a été soigneusement
répété après avec une chorégraphe
l'entrée en scène le discours ou encore
la démarche et j'imagine que plus
l'après-midi passait plus la pression
montée oui alors deux heures avant le
grand show chaque candidat est passé
entre les mains des coiffeurs et Barber
histoire de de peaufiner leurs look
ensuite tous sont allés se changer avant
que la cérémonie ne commence la pression
est montée d'un cran vous l'aurez
compris mais pas question de se laisser
aller les 28 candidats ont d'ailleurs pu
profiter des derniers conseils de Lenny
labourelle alors c'était le Mister
France 2022 il a assisté à la dernière
répétition mais il était aussi là pour
conseiller et encourager les prétendants
au titre il avait le rôle un petit peu
de de grand frère écouter je suis là
justement en tant que
frère justement pour aider les candidats
vraiment les motiver à leur donner des
petits conseils comme tu as pu voir
justement et vraiment bah les motiver
surtout et vraiment bah je suis là pour
essayer les conseiller de les quadriller
un peu et quand ils sont un peu
bordelaise qui partent un peu comme des
foufous ben je suis là vraiment pour les
remettre d'aplomb et là cérémonie a
débuté aux alentours de 20h15 est-ce
qu'il y avait de l'ambiance au théâtre
de Poissy alors beaucoup d'ambiance
beaucoup de monde si environ 1200
personnes dans le public des fans mais
aussi les proches et parfois les les
familles de certains candidats beaucoup
de bruit de cris et d'applaudissements
notamment pendant certaines épreuves
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous connaissez
sur le plateau peut-être les différentes
étapes de de Mister France
en termes de différentes étapes il y a
plusieurs étapes Miss France il y a un
test de culture générale c'est ça il y a
un test de culture générale défilé on
imagine peut-être répondre à des
questions du public je sais pas alors il
y avait pas de question du public il y
avait un test de culture générale pas de
costume traditionnel malheureusement je
vous sens un petit peu un petit peu déçu
surtout qui Gabriel alors il y aura un
discours il y a eu un discours il y a
une petite chorégraphie pour l'ouverture
de la soirée un défilé en peignoir et
bien évidemment un défiler en
sous-vêtements de quoi réchauffer
l'ambiance dans la salle du théâtre deux
Poissy et pour les candidats de montrer
leur meilleur atouts l'élection de
Mister France n'est pas seulement un
beau visage et un corps parfait tout de
même non alors vous aviez eu raison
Gabriel il y a eu un test de culture
générale mais on n'a pas eu les
résultats plus sérieusement chaque
candidat défendait une cause et chacun a
eu l'occasion d'en parler sur scène
alors il y a eu la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes la lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire la
prévention contre les addictions et la
délinquance la délinquance pardon ou
encore la lutte contre la maltraitance
animale et les actions en faveur de
environnement avant que le jury présidé
par Nathalie Marquay Pernaut ancienne
Miss France ne se retire les candidats
ont pu défiler en costume on les voit
l'image justement les les candidats j'en
profite pour accueillir Florence
mercadeshockey qui va nous parler de son
exposition dans un sens si on peut
remettre la petite image en plateau
est-ce que vous avez peut-être un
préféré un candidat préféré regarder on
les voit alors on voit pas forcément
leur représentation
de région mais voilà plusieurs candidats
j'ai dit tout à l'heure 29 il y en avait
en réalité 28 je sais pas est-ce que
vous avez repéré un préféré non
peut-être pas en plateau
particulièrement de mon côté
lequel était votre préféré votre favori
moi en plus j'ai pu échanger avec eux
mon favori c'était Mister Réunion où il
y avait aussi Mister province au Pays
Basque voilà c'était mes préférés et
alors tous vos vœux n'ont
malheureusement pas été exaucés
malheureusement non ni pour Mister
Île-de-France le gagnant de la soirée
c'est Mister Corse il s'appelle Lysandre
van Wilders et devient donc Mister
France 2023 il est diplômé d'une licence
de STAPS un mètre 87 88 kg il est assez
timide mais il devrait représenter
dignement l'île de beauté et même la
France écoutait sa réaction après son
élection pour moi l'étape la plus
difficile c'était vraiment l'étape où
j'ai dû parler devant le public parce
que comme je l'ai dit je suis quelqu'un
de réservé de base et franchement je
suis je les avais comme ça alors moi ma
cause c'est l'environnement comme j'ai
dit tout à l'heure dans mon discours
j'ai vraiment envie de m'engager dans
cette direction parce que c'est hyper
important pour moi j'avais pour idée de
faire la prévention moi de mon côté
j'agis de manière individuelle au
quotidien je ramasse des déchets est-ce
que tout le monde peut faire et
j'encourage fortement à le faire
d'ailleurs alors les ordres remportent
donc quelques cadeaux un des partenaires
et puis surtout il représentera
maintenant la France lors de différents
événements médiatiques c'est le cas pour
Miss France il y a Miss France ces deux
fines est-ce que là il y a aussi des
dauphins peut-être des prix
supplémentaires dans cette élection
alors oui Mister France 2022 Leny
tabouret la remis un prix un peu spécial
c'est l'écharpe de la sympathie à Mister
Roussillon alors c'est juste le candidat
le plus sympathique qui a été élu par
ses par ses les autres mystères
finalement on a eu Mister France
Languedoc qui a reçu l'écharpe du
quatrième dauphin Mister France Mister
France Bourgogne Franche-Comté qui a été
3e dauphin Mister France
Nord-Pas-de-Calais deuxième dauphin et
bonne surprise lors de cette soirée car
ces mystères Mayotte qui a remporté
l'écharpe du premier de fin le tout
après une présélection le vote du public
par SMS et le choix du jury et dans tout
ça vraiment rien pour notre local de
l'étape Mister Île-de-France alors non
non malheureusement il y a même pas été
sélectionné dans les 12 candidats du
coup pour pour la demi-finale entre
guillemets alors je voudrais juste
préciser que chaque candidat a cette
élection ont vendu les des tickets de
tombola à leurs proches à leurs amis à
leur famille et même pendant plusieurs
événements et en fait donc le prix qui a
été qui a été récolté enfin le voilà
tout ce qui a été récolté pour pour ces
tickets tombola servent à soutenir
l'association l'enfant bleu donc il y a
eu plus de 3600 euros qui ont été
récoltés pour pour l'association merci
Jessie merci d'avoir suivi merci pour
Radio sensation est-ce également pour TV
78 cette soirée on pourra retrouver
l'intégralité des interviews et les
coulisses sur les réseaux sociaux de
radio sensation d'ailleurs je crois que
les candidatures pour Mr France 2024
sont déjà ouvertes ce sont déjà ouvertes
je vais peut-être aller tenter ma chance
je vais pouvoir je vais peut-être aussi
y réfléchir un petit avis sur l'élection
Mr France Florence Mercat de choqué
France a priori égalité des sexes
en avant beaucoup moins Mister France
donc ça c'est bien d'en parler ça s'est
passé en plus dans les Yvelines du côté
du théâtre 2 Poissy donc je le disais il
y a Florence mercatoquet qui nous a
rejoint en plateau et généralement c'est
plutôt l'avocate que l'on reçoit
l'avocate spécialiste du droit du
travail nous recevons dans cette
émission La changement de décor de
personnage non pas mais de décor vous
allez enfier votre casquette d'artiste
peintre puisque nous allons parler avec
vous d'une exposition vous allez
proposer au prisme les tableaux vos
tableaux seront exposés aux prismes du 7
mars jusqu'au 25 mars vous passez du
barreau au pinceau de la robe noire aux
couleurs de la toile mais les deux
activités ce que elles peuvent avoir un
lien est-ce que en tout cas vous arrivez
à trouver un lien entre l'activité
d'avocate et celle d'artiste peintre
est-ce qu'il y a des
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup entre les
deux univers il y a des ponts il y a des
points communs je pense que le premier
point commun
un avocate et peintre c'est la
créativité
puisque dans mon métier il faut faire
preuve de créativité de stratégie
d'écoute de combativité
et puis absorber l'histoire alors là on
l'espèce on absorbe l'histoire d'un
autre ou d'une autre on absorbe ses
émotions qui peuvent rejoindre nos
propres émotions d'ailleurs et on
s'expose comme avocat mais on s'expose
pour un autre c'est bien nous qui nous
exposons mais on s'expose en portant
l'histoire d'un autre
peintre c'est
c'est une toute autre histoire mais
c'est de la créativité aussi beaucoup de
créativité et que de la créativité mais
de la créativité qui vient d'émotion qui
vient de notre histoire et pas que de la
nôtre puisqu'on est faite des histoires
aussi des gens qu'on rencontre de des
histoires qu'on partage avec d'autres et
donc il y a des liens vraiment entre la
transmission d'une histoire mais qui est
plus la nôtre que celle que je porte
quand je suis avocate mais il y a
beaucoup de
beaucoup de points communs donc
l'exposition s'appelle le paysage je
l'avais pas précisé donc exposition du 7
au 25 mars au prisme à Élancourt on
pourrait même dire presque les paysages
si on peut revoir peut-être
quelques-unes de vos peintures
s'afficher on va voir voilà sur les
clichés qui sont qui sont proposés des
paysages variés et souvent reviennent la
mer l'océan en quoi c'est une source
d'inspiration
la mère a la mer c'est une très grande
partie de ma vie
j'habite pas au bord de la mer là mais
j'habite en partie au bord de la mer
j'essaye de partager ma vie entre la
Normandie et la région parisienne mais
j'ai tout le temps été au bord de la mer
quand j'étais jeune et moins jeune et la
mère c'est une source d'inspiration
enfin on le voit bien au travers de très
nombreux peintres c'est une source
d'inspiration infinie je veux dire la
mer c'est l'horizon c'est l'infini c'est
une multitude de de couleurs il y a une
part d'abstraction la mer c'est de
l'abstraction comme le ciel et en même
temps c'est quelque chose de très
concret et puis c'est mille teinte le
bleu le bleu on le retrouve beaucoup
dans mes peintures c'est une de mes
couleurs préférées mais le bleu le bleu
de la mer ça change en fonction des
saisons ça change en fonction du soleil
ça change en fonction des nuages c'est
la lumière la mer c'est la lumière et
c'est extraordinaire à peindre la
couleur bleue est très présente
forcément avec avec le merco comment
vous travaillez comment vous viennent
les inspirations comment se passe le
travail
alors c'est un peu une maturation ce que
des fois j'arrive devant mon devant ma
toile blanche et en fait ce sont les
c'est le geste et les couleurs au départ
je des fois je ne sais pas où je veux
aller je sais que j'ai envie de peindre
avec telle couleur telle couleur je sais
que j'ai envie de faire telle forme tel
aller dans telle sens ou dans tel autre
et puis après ça se construit et c'est
au fur et à mesure de la construction du
tableau par ses couleurs par la matière
parce que j'aime beaucoup peindre avec
une matière un peu épaisse en
introduisant aussi bien des coquillages
écrasés on est en mettant du charbon en
mettant du bois j'ai un produit beaucoup
de matière
et donc au fil de la création du tableau
et ben voilà je pars et puis très
souvent je me retrouve à découvrir qu'au
fur et à mesure je suis en train de
faire un paysage et je trouve que les
paysages ça a quelque chose de tellement
inspirant tellement
ça adoucit aussi même s'ils sont des
paysages un peu durs de montagne mais
c'est extrêmement apaisant et donc très
souvent je me retrouve en étant parti je
recule je me dis bah oui ça c'est je
vais aller dans telle direction voilà et
donc vous l'avez dit vous utilisez
différents matériaux différents outils
aussi avec le à côté du pinceau il y a
le couteau notamment le couteau c'est
très c'est le matériau le plus
intéressant pour travailler pour faire
de l'épaisseur puisque avec un couteau
on peut faire plus ou moins épais on
peut faire très raclée mais on peut
aussi faire de l'épaisseur importante et
donc ça c'est j'utilise beaucoup le
couteau il y a des tableaux que je fais
uniquement au pinceau et puis d'autres
que je ne fais qu'au couteau et donc
dans l'expo il y a des il y a de tout un
petit tour de table est-ce que ça vous
la peinture en général le j'ai jamais
réussi à en faire mais vous êtes vous
êtes passionnés c'est ça qui est hyper
intéressant je trouve dans un artiste
quand on voit la passion
artistique mais c'est vrai que ça vide
la tête et encore plus des paysages
comme ça donc c'est sûr quand je me mets
à peindre
je vois pas le temps passer on est on
est ailleurs quoi on est dans la couleur
dans la peinture de on est embarqué
complètement et il commence à entrer
dans votre vie la peinture c'est rentré
assez tardivement dans ma vie quand
j'étais quand j'étais petite à l'école
j'étais super nul en dessin donc voilà
et puis j'ai une amie qui peignait
depuis très longtemps et qui m'a dit
m'écoute toi qui parce que j'ai toujours
été dans les musées mes parents sont des
collectionneurs enfin j'ai toujours
baigné dans dans le monde artistique ma
mère aussi était artiste enfin donc j'ai
quand même un certain nombre de
d'éléments qui m'ont amené et elle me
dit mais écoute bien et donc je suis
venu chez elle et puis je me suis mise à
peindre elle me dit mais si vas-y et là
j'ai eu un espèce de public de et puis
c'est parti c'est un refuge on peut le
présenter comme ça ah non c'est pas un
refuge parce qu'un refuge c'est un peu
je me mets dans ma bulle et non c'est
c'est au contraire c'est c'est de
l'énergie c'est pour moi c'est
extrêmement plein de joie et plein
d'énergie et d'aller à la rencontre des
autres avec une exposition ça c'est
important oui c'est important parce que
d'abord j'ai l'habitude de par mon
métier de nos tempéraments d'aller vers
les autres mais là de pouvoir recevoir
les critiques je trouve ça très
important aussi qu'on me dise bah non ça
ça me plaît pas parce que si parce que
ça je trouve que c'est aussi ça fait
avancer et puis recevoir des compliments
c'est toujours sympa quoi
7 au 25 mars c'est du côté du prisme à
Élancourt et ses exposition s'appelle le
paysage merci d'être venu en parler dans
le 7 8 merci à vous de m'avoir reçu
c'est l'heure d'ouvrir une page pour à
présent
[Musique]
et on va débuter par du cyclisme ce
week-end le Paris-Nice est parti pour la
14e année consécutive des Yvelines à La
Verrière c'était la ville étape pour
cette première étape du Paris-Nice
aujourd'hui c'est la petite commune de
basainville qui a également accueilli le
départ de l'épreuve pour la première
fois Michael et le midro était sur place
pendant ces deux jours
[Musique]
ce dimanche 5 mars c'est le grand départ
du Paris-Nice il s'élance ici depuis les
Yvelines depuis à 14 ans et cette année
c'est la commune de la verrière qui a
été sélectionné pour le grand départ de
l'épreuve allez c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est une grande première pour la
commune de 6000 habitants qui a
travaillé pendant plusieurs mois pour
préparer cette journée placée sous le
signe du cyclisme très très grande
fierté pour la verrière de d'accueillir
une compétition hors normes avec des
milliers de spectateurs qui sont
attendus avec beaucoup de
téléspectateurs du monde entier qui
auront les yeux rivés sur la verrière et
le Mesnil-Saint-Denis donc c'est une
fierté on a aussi un très beau village
d'animation et j'ai pu voir beaucoup de
joie beaucoup de sourires pour tous les
âges avec notamment de nombreux enfants
sur une thématique très populaire le
vélo qui parle à tout le monde qui
rassemble et donc c'est un moment unique
pour la verrière pour l'histoire le
départ est programmé à côté de la mairie
de la verrière et les veyrierois sont
venus nombreux près du podium pour
suivre la présentation des équipes
j'avais plaisir parce qu'on voit un truc
comme ça
donc
pour une fois on voit quelque chose de
bien quoi de c'est bien organisé ça on
se prend parce que pour la première fois
que je vois ça depuis
la bêtises depuis 35 ans que je suis là
c'est la première fois donc voilà c'est
bien pour la verrière je suis content de
moi je vois le monde que sont là à La
Verrière c'est la première fois qu'on
pourra faire la verrière et je suis
content
de voir en vrai le Parisis n'attire pas
que des supporters locaux la Course au
Soleil attire également des supporters
du monde entier comme ces fans
colombiens venus soutenir un membre de
l'équipe inéos sur les routes divinoises
on est passionné du cyclisme depuis
toute la vie mon père qui est juste à
côté depuis plus de 40 ans et voilà on a
ça dans le sang donc on est content
d'être là de partager avec tous les tous
les équipes et voilà c'est un plaisir
pour nous un public qui a pu approcher
au plus près les stars du cyclisme les
bus des équipes avaient été installées à
côté du quartier du Bois de l'Etang le
vélo va partout
le stade il couvre toute la France nous
sommes pas comme le football ou on doit
cantonner des gens dans un dans un stade
là on est vraiment ouvert au public là
depuis qu'il n'y a plus le moins le
covid les parkings sont sont ouverts
donc les gens peuvent toucher les
coureurs peuvent toucher les Mbappe du
vélo donc nous sommes également
satisfaits de cela les spectateurs
présents ont pu voir les deux cyclistes
les plus en vue du moment le sloven
tellage bugatcha et le Danoy
et de quoi remporter les trois derniers
tours de France Parigny c'est une avant
première avant que les deux hommes
s'affront de nouveau sur la Grande
Boucle cet été c'est un plateau
absolument phénoménal oui il a la
revanche du dernier Tour de France qui a
qui a enthousiasmé tout le monde
c'est formidable de l'avoir dès le mois
de mars ça va être un combat des chefs
ils ont montré dans les premières
courses de l'année en Espagne chacun de
leur côté qu'ils étaient très très forts
qu'ils ont gagné quasiment tout toutes
les courses dans laquelle ils étaient
inscrits et là c'est vraiment le combat
des chefs qui nous attend avec d'autres
coureurs de talents j'en ai très
satisfait parce que si ces coureurs la
Vienne c'est que on leur propose quelque
chose de bien au niveau sportif donc on
est on est nous sommes vraiment
satisfaits la venue de ces sportifs de
Roland a fait le bonheur des plus jeunes
venus à la chasse aux autographes un
autographe et une photo si un grand fan
de pogacia
qu'est-ce que tu aimes bien chez lui
j'aime tout chez lui c'est une grande
chance de voir les cyclistes et je suis
très contente la première fois je vais
voir les églises on va faire on va voir
les signatures et tout ah ça ça va être
cool très bien on est allé prendre
quelques signatures de 5 cyclistes et ça
se passe très bien en ce moment bon là
on attend c'est sûr que c'est un peu
long mais sinon ça va là on est chaud
une fois la présentation des équipes
terminées direction la ligne de départ
pour les 217 cours engagés au départ de
l'épreuve devant des milliers de
spectateurs regroupés de chaque côté de
la route
[Musique]
après 169,4 km un tracé qui a conduit
les coureurs dans la vallée de Chevreuse
et la côte des 17 tournants c'est le
champion de Belgique team merdier qui
s'impose au bout de l'effort sur la
dernière ligne droite située au
Mesnil-Saint-Denis
[Musique]
deuxième jour sur ce Paris - Nice 2023
aujourd'hui le Paris-Nice partira depuis
une petite commune des Yvelines c'est
basé en ville une commune de 1500
habitants direction Fontainebleau
[Musique]
la petite commune accueille l'épreuve
pour la première fois le maire de
Bazainville a encore du mal à réaliser
aujourd'hui ce qui me plaît le plus
c'est de voir beaucoup de gens venir sur
Bazainville et j'espère que notre
village leur plaira de voir les élèves
de l'école heureux comme tout
en voyant les cyclistes les motards et
toute l'organisation je pense pas qu'on
puisse nous le reposer et donc ça sera
une fois mais je vous dis quand ça sera
fini je pense que je pourrais savourer
pour cette journée inédite la commune
avait décidé de sortir le grand jeu des
produits locaux du pays ou d'années
étaient présentés au public devant le
podium les vitrines étaient aux couleurs
du Parisis pour l'occasion vous l'aurez
compris les bazins-villois avec cocher
la dette de l'événement dans leur
calendrier pour ne pas manquer cette
course
j'avais jamais vu moi il était jamais
venu
mais c'est bien c'est très bien le
cyclisme que j'adore ça c'est pas dur
pour moi mais bon ça ça réveille le
maire est content c'est très bien ça
vaut le coup c'est une sacrée animation
ça plaît beaucoup je crois il y a du
monde on attendait ceci mars avec
impatience on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
ce genre de véhicule dans cette petite
commune on a pas mal de bouchons
malheureusement aux heures de pointe
quand les gens rentrent de travailler
mais c'est jamais des des bus et des
vélos comme ça installez les bus des
équipes cyclistes dans des petites
communes du département c'est l'un des
objectifs affichés tous les ans par les
organisateurs chaque année dans les
Yvelines une petite commune du
département et sélectionnée c'est le
vélo qui veut ça c'est notre sport qui
veut ça et on sent on ne s'en plaint pas
les les vedettes doivent d'être partout
partout même dans les petites communes
donc pour nous c'est bien une grande
ville des Yvelines le dimanche une
petite ville le lundi un concept qui
devrait durer encore pendant de
nombreuses années le département a signé
une convention avec les organisateurs
jusqu'en 2025 vous le voyez la vallée de
Chevreuse est renommée dans le monde
entier aussi pour pour pour le vélo mon
interrupteur qui est vraiment fait pour
le vélo parce qu'on a à la fois des
dénivelé fabuleux on a à la fois des
fleuves des forêts mais aussi un énorme
capital de Me de patrimoine qui fait
aussi que ça nous donne des images dans
le monde entier assez fabuleuses et je
crois que c'est aussi ça les Yvelines
c'est aussi territoire qui est aussi
fait pour le vélo fait pour être vu à la
télévision ce lundi 6 mars à benzinville
le départ était donné à 12h50 en
présence de grands noms du cyclisme les
bazins Villois et basins-villoise
pourront dire qu'ils ont vu dans leur
communauté deutschoga char yunas Wingard
Brian Coquard et Tim Berli
[Musique]
le Paris Nice dans les églises c'est
désormais terminé mais rassurez-vous le
pari historien l'année prochaine
c'est une les prochaines villes qui
accueilleront l'étape sont connus en
début d'année à 2024
il était sur les routes du Paris 10 mais
il est bien revenu en plateau Michel et
le minero bonsoir il est parti à 12h50
mais vous avez eu le temps de revenir 30
minutes donc ça va donc ce sport bien
sûr de la rédaction de TV 78 alors
comment ça s'est déroulé sur place cet
événement et bien ça c'est très bien
déroulé je le couvre à peu près depuis
une dizaine d'années ce Paris-Nice et ça
c'est une nouvelle fois très bien
déroulée que ce soit la verrière ou à
Bazainville à La Verrière c'était une
grande première comme pour Bazainville
et forcément quand c'est une grande
première dans les Yvelines il y a plus
d'excitation les habitants sont
émerveillés par par l'événement et
c'était une très belle expérience encore
cette année cette année 2023 sur les
routes très très beau plateau avec le
duel pogaccha vinigord qui est reproposé
c'était duel du dernier Tour de France
là il est reposé sur les rôles du Paris
10 la question prud'hommes l'a dit dans
dans le reportage il y avait très peu de
chance pour qu'on voit
sportif présent sur ce Paris-Nice 2023
et finalement ça a été le cas et c'est
peut-être le plus beau plateau depuis 15
ou 20 ans d'après les organisateurs on
n'oublie pas les Français non Bryan
Coquard on va maintenant et Romain
Bardet on va passer aux autres résultats
sportifs du weekend bien sûr pas que du
cyclisme même si c'était l'événement
fort du weekend dans les Yvelines il
veut aussi du football les clubs
vivinois étaient sur les terrains dans
le championnat de National très mauvaise
opération pour le FC Versailles les
hommes de Chris se sont inclinés à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de Nancy le
score 2-1 pourtant versa avait ouvert le
score par Thibault Jacques sur penalty
au classement les versets premiers il y
a encore deux semaines se retrouvent à
la troisième place du championnat après
cette deuxième défaite consécutive une
division plus bas un mot de National 2 à
présent alors si Versailles calme ce
n'est pas le cas de Poissy l'Épic saké
se sont imposés 3 à 0 ce samedi sur la
pelouse de la réserve de Guingamp à
l'occasion de la 20e journée du
championnat au classement l'as Poissy et
troisième avec 25 points engrangé depuis
le début de la saison par la prison
rugby alors dans le championnat de
fédéral de plaisir s'incline 34 à 17 sur
la pelouse de Courbevoie lors du choc de
la 78e journée et de son côté Versailles
s'impose 48 à 3 à l'extérieur chez
Boulogne-Billancourt au classement
plaisir et troisième et Versailles et 5e
lors de la prochaine journée ce dimanche
Versailles recevra Courbevoie et plaisir
recevoir de mon un mot de football
américain donnez-moi des bonnes
nouvelles s'il vous plaît nickel dans
cette deuxième division qu'est-ce que
d'or ils ont stoppé l'hémorragie mais
ils n'ont toujours pas à gagner en
deuxième division les Templiers
d'Élancourt n'ont pu faire mieux que
match nul ce samedi à domicile face aux
Viking de Villeneuve-d'Ascq en quatre
matchs les élans courtois ont perdu deux
matchs ils ont perdu un autre match sur
tapis hiver et ils ont donc fait un
match nul sont pour l'instant dernier de
la poule bien sûr une première victoire
dans ce championnat de Division 2 casque
d'or de la course à pied à présent et le
compte à rebours est lancé dans moins de
deux semaines le 18 mars 126
participants vont prendre le départ de
l'échote de Paris au programme de cette
saison édition de la Marche Nordique et
des trails les preuves bien sûr c'est le
80 km et qui partira de l'île de loisirs
de 50 ans à venir avec le final un final
classique au premier étage de la Tour
Eiffel et pour en parler un invité avec
nous en visio c'est Hervé par dye
bonsoir Oui bonsoir alors vous êtes l'un
des organisateurs alors plus de 12000
participants pour cette édition de l'éco
trail de Paris est-ce que vous êtes
satisfait de ce nombre d'inscrits
oui très satisfait donc on va être
proche des 13000 coureurs inscrits donc
après une année des années covid un peu
compliqué nous sommes très satisfaits de
ce retour à la normale et on va donc
accueillir 13000 coureurs donc notamment
à peu près 85% sont des Franciliens
alors 85% de Franciliens 12000 coureurs
au total sur l'épreuve phare le 80 km
avec je le disais des parts de l'île de
loisirs le final au premier étage de la
Tour Eiffel combien de combien
d'inscrits sur cette épreuve sur
l'épreuve du 80 km on attend environ
2500 participants en effet qui vont
prendre donc le départ le samedi 18 mars
avec c'est arrivé exceptionnel au
premier étage de la Tour Eiffel après
avoir traversé donc trois départements
avec les Yvelines les Hauts-de-Seine et
Paris on peut dire que c'est l'épreuve
reine de l'écoterais même si on a
compris à plusieurs épreuves au
programme mais ce 80 km c'est quand même
on va dire la figure de proue de l'éco
trail de Paris
alors c'est vraiment en effet l'épreuve
reine n'est pas phares pour les adeptes
de trail parce que les coterais de Paris
c'est vraiment une invitation justement
à découvrir à redécouvrir le patrimoine
de la région Île-de-France et le 80 km
justement va faire traverser les
soulignes et Hauts-de-Seine et Paris et
ils vont traverser des nombreux sites
qui sont emblématiques de la région
Île-de-France avec l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on va passer
devant le vélodrome ensuite on va
s'attaquer à Buc donc le château de Buc
il y aura un ravitaillement on va
rejoindre ensuite les forêts
franciliennes de l'Ouest franciliens
donc avec la forêt de Manial de
Versailles ensuite Meudon fausse repose
le domaine national de Saint-Cloud et
puis on va longer les pour terminer les
10 derniers kilomètres sur les le nom
des quais de scène pour rallier le
premier étage de la Tour Eiffel c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment un magnifique
parcours pour mettre en avant donc tout
ce patrimoine de l'ouest francilien
patrimoine donc naturel historique et
culturel qu'on voit l'image un premier
étage de la Tour Eiffel après c'est 80
km qui avec des jambes coupées voilà qui
a tendance à couper les jambes des des
coureurs une épreuve très difficile
nickel oui qu'est-ce qui fait la force
de l'écoterelle à votre avis
la force de l'écotrail donc c'est déjà
c'est en effet ce que je disais c'est
vraiment la découverte et la
redécouverte de la région Île-de-France
et pas juste une course à pied c'est
vraiment c'est mettre en avant tout ce
patrimoine assez exceptionnel que l'on a
dans l'ouest francilien notamment avec
dans les Yvelines parce qu'on a deux
départs exceptionnels donc on a 80 km en
effet qui part de l'île de loisirs mais
on a également le 45 km qui est une
épreuve tard et qui parle du jardin du
château de Versailles le long du grand
canal donc c'est vraiment des des
paysages
somptueux on va faire découvrir un assez
coureurs de trail et que ça soit sur le
81 le 45 le 30 km le 18 et le 10 km
c'est vraiment un réel plaisir de venir
participer à l'écotrail Paris sans
compter
pour en parler aussi
et finalement tout le monde peut
participer à l'écotrail si on voit
toutes les distances
alors si on voit toutes les distances en
effet
on les adepte de course longues ils vont
faire le 80 ceux qui sont plutôt
marathoniens vont plutôt s'attaquer aux
45 km
après on a on a un effet une épreuve un
peu intermédiaire qui est 30 km il y a
le 18 km qui existe depuis 2008 depuis
sa création et on a sorti donc il y a
maintenant deux ans le 10 km donc une
épreuve finalement qui est pour la
découverte de la course nature et ça et
ça c'est intéressant aussi pour pour
venir découvrir déjà ce que c'est qu'un
trail et pour maintenant certains déjà
certains coureurs ont fait 18 ils
reviennent l'année d'après pour faire le
30 et jusqu'au 80 km donc c'est ça qui
est assez sympa
et quel est le profil des participants à
l'écoterais leur voulait dire selon les
distances peut-être des profils qui
diffèrent 80 km on imagine ça demande
beaucoup beaucoup d'entraînements on
croise d'ailleurs assez souvent des
figures assez connues du trek francilien
j'ai oublié son nom mais il y a
casquette verte notamment qui revient à
chaque année en tout cas il est
reconnaissable par cette casquette verte
qu'il porte c'est quoi le profil de
découvrir de l'écotrail
le profil des cotrame donc c'est ce que
je disais par rapport donc déjà la
participation des Franciliens donc c'est
85% de coureurs franciliens et dans ces
coureurs donc on a 30% de femmes et et
70% d'hommes donc qui sont répartis
plutôt plus d'hommes on va dire sur les
parcours longs comme le 80 km et il y a
plus de femmes sur les marchandiques et
la répartition en effet elle elle a lieu
en effet sur
on va dire ça la moyenne d'âge elle est
à peu près de 40 ans la moyenne d'âge
sur l'ensemble des courses et on a aussi
des fidèles sur cette course
l'écoterelle on l'a fait bien Parmentier
par exemple qui habite à montim retenus
qui a fait toutes les éditions sauf une
je crois parce qu'il avait un autre
trail à ce moment-là il devrait revenir
à nouveau cette année et il y a
également aussi des Dialo aussi un Igny
Montain qui court quant à lui un pied nu
pieds nus il est parti pieds nus de
l'île d'oisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour aller
jusqu'à la tour Eiffel c'était il y a
deux ans je crois et il a il a fait
trois quatre fois
on l'imagine qui se développe d'année en
année vous avez cette impression là
alors on a développé donc moi je suis
fondateur de l'événement donc c'était en
2008 qu'on avait fait la première
édition c'était un 16 février il faisait
très froid mais ça ça a marché dès la
première édition
et depuis c'est assez développé parce
que je rappelle les chiffres on était à
peine 900 inscrits sur le 80 km la
première édition et maintenant on est on
est proche de de 3000 coureurs quand
même donc c'est c'est vraiment
impressionnant de voir cette
cette comment dire c'est pouvoir qui se
sont inscrits de plus en plus nombreux
chaque année alors connu quelques
quelques coins des Yvelines peut-être
une dernière question qu'est-ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter pour cette nouvelle
édition
alors pour cette nouvelle édition
on peut on peut nous souhaiter un
finalement une belle météo ce serait
sympa un peu un peu de soleil et pas de
trop froid pour une fois on va vous
souhaiter cette météo merci Hervé d'être
venu en parler dans cette édition du 7 8
on rappelle la date un 18 mars pour les
côtes règles de Paris avec un 80 km qui
partira et depuis l'île de loisirs de 50
ans divine un deuxième parcours dans les
Yvelines de 45 km également au départ de
Versailles merci d'avoir été avec nous
un dernier mot de sport Michael avec une
compétition insolite qui avait lieu ce
week-end dans les Yvelines le
championnat de France de bras de fer
était organisé ce samedi à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye aux gymnase
Philippe pivert l'événement officiel a
été organisé par la Fédération Française
de force des dizaines de clubs de toute
la France ont fait le déplacement pour
ce rendez-vous le reportage complet sera
retrouvé demain à partir de 18h sur TV
78 dans le 7 8
j'ai pas pu échanger avec lui mais je
vais lui demander demain donc on
retrouve le reportage sur TV 78 et vous
vous retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine dans le 7 8 pour de nouveau
sportif merci d'avoir été avec nous
avant de vous quitter on va jeter un
dernier coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
mardi matin le ciel sera dégagé sur
l'ensemble du département quelques
nuages à prévoir mais nous aurons tout
de même de belles éclairs si au niveau
des températures 4 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans les Versailles
fera 3 degrés à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi prévoyait de la pluie sur
une bonne partie des Yvelines seul le
secteur de Rambouillet devrait être
épargné selon Météo France côté
température 8 degrés vers ou dans
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles comptez à
7 degrés à Rambouillet demain ce sera la
sainte Félicité voilà c'est la fin de ce
7 8 merci et de votre fidélité et on se
retrouve bien sûr dès demain pour une
nouvelle édition belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]